Traductor: Claudia Viveros
Revisor: Frank Zegarra
Sientes los ojos pesados,
se te cierran poco a poco...
Pero, ¡espera!
Apenas es hora del almuerzo
y aún tienes mucho por hacer.
¿Te ayudaría tomar una siesta?
0 ¿te haría el día más pesado?
El sueño, nocturno o de siestas,
se compone de ciclos de sueño
de aproximadamente 90 minutos,
y de cuatro fases cada ciclo.
Una siesta puede durar entre cinco minutos
y tres horas,
y puede incluir ciclos completos de sueño
o solo algunas fases.
Cuando te duermes, entras a la etapa 1:
los primeros dos a cinco minutos.
Sigue la etapa 2, durante 30 minutos.
En esta, la temperatura corporal baja,
los músculos se relajan
y la respiración y el ritmo cardíaco
se vuelven más regulares.
Tus neuronas se encienden simultáneamente,
creando ondas de actividad
que se extienden a través del córtex,
marcadas por explosiones rápidas
de actividad neuronal
llamadas husos de sueño.
En la etapa 3, o la de sueño profundo,
el movimiento de las ondas incrementa
conforme las neuronas se conectan.
Esta fase dura de 20 a 30 min
y es donde duermes más profundo.
Después, entras al sueño REM, que dura
entre 10 y 20 min en una siesta.
En REM, el cerebro se vuelve más activo,
casi como cuando estás despierto.
Cuando el REM termina,
se ha completado un ciclo del sueño.
Bien, pero ¿la siesta
te hará sentir mejor?
Bueno, eso depende de varias cosas,
en especial las fases del sueño
que alcances en la siesta.
Una siesta de 30 min, por ejemplo,
llega a la fase 2 del sueño.
En la fase 2 el sueño se asocia
con la potenciación a largo plazo,
se cree que ese proceso fortalece
la sinapsis entre las neuronas,
el cual es esencial para el aprendizaje.
Una siesta de 20 a 30 min no llega
al sueño profundo de la fase 3,
lo cual facilita que nos despertemos.
Una siesta de 30 a 60 min, por otro lado,
tiene los beneficios de la fase 2
y también alcanza el sueño profundo
de la fase 3.
En la fase 3, varias partes del cerebro
trabajan juntas y transfieren información
de la memoria a corto plazo,
a la de largo plazo,
lo que estabiliza y fortalece
la memoria a largo plazo
conectando neuronas en huso
con ondas lentas.
La fase 3 es la más difícil
para despertarse.
Mientras una siesta de 30 a 60 min
puede traer beneficios cognitivos,
esos beneficios a menudo no surten efecto
hasta 15 min después de despertar.
Siestas de 60 a 90 min
entran en la fase REM.
Durante REM, la corteza prefrontal,
la responsable del control
de la inhibición y la cognición,
se vuelve mucho menos activa.
Mientras, la amígdala
y la corteza cingulada,
regiones asociadas a la emoción
y motivación, están muy activas.
Algunos investigadores han planteado
que esta combinación
produce sueños extraños
durante la fase REM:
la disminución del control de inhibición
y cognición puede causar esas asociaciones
y, gracias a la amígdala y
la actividad de la corteza cingulada,
esas asociaciones pueden ser
sobre temas cargados de emoción.
Algunos investigadores creen que
esta fase podría ayudarnos
a hacer conexiones innovadoras
entre ideas al despertar.
La actividad cerebral en REM
está más cerca del despertar,
podría ser más fácil despertar en REM
que en la fase 3,
aunque la siesta sea más larga.
La hora del día también es importante.
La necesidad de sueño de la fase 3
incrementa progresivamente
a lo largo del día.
Si tomas una siesta más tarde,
puedes perder la cantidad de sueño
necesaria para dormir en la noche.
Esto no pasa en el sueño REM.
Los periodos más largos de REM
ocurren en la mañana,
las siestas de la mañana son de REM,
las de medio día tienen partes iguales
de REM y sueño profundo,
y las de la tarde contienen
más sueño profundo.
Aparte de todo esto, parece
que estamos divididos
entre los que toman siesta y los que no.
Los que la toman han mostrado más
beneficios cognitivos por tomar siesta
que los que no la toman.
Algunos investigadores creen
que podría deberse a que
los que toman siesta duermen más ligero
y pasan fácilmente por las fases.
Mientras que los que no la toman
duermen más profundo cuando la toman,
y se sienten adormilados después.
Entonces, ¿ayuda tomar siesta?
Bueno, solo hay una manera de saberlo...